hi and welcome back to another episode
of this study with me series learning
some more of the concepts and math
behind quantum mechanics this episode is
going to be a little bit of a step back
from the previous two and we're going to
look in more detail to truly understand
what it means to observe and measure a
quantum state if you haven't seen the
previous two episodes don't worry so
much none of that math is really going
to come into this video but I hope that
all of it will come together in the next
video after this so let's start off
we're on brilliant and we're in the
quantum objects course we're looking at
what it even means to be dealing with
quantum particles so atoms are certainly
small enough to behave as quantum
objects but they're very I guess large
on this relative scale and they contain
many complex parts so what we're going
to use and some experiments here is the
neutron this is a particle that's in the
atom makes up the nucleus and the
neutron doesn't have a charge so it is
neutral a lot of work went into
understanding neutrons around the time
of the Manhattan Project when they were
involved as an important part in making
nuclear power plants and atomic bombs
they relate to moderating the nuclear
chain reactions that go on in these
processes so that was I guess worse a
lot of the interest in neutrons came
from but what we're going to be using
neutrons here for is something I have
mentioned before which is the
stern-gerlach experiment and that is
something where you fire neutrons
through magnets and you learn about
fundamental quantum properties such as
spin so in this picture you can see here
we are we've got a hot nuclear oven and
it is I guess spitting out a single
Neutron one of the first questions here
too
establish some understanding is what
kind of path do we expect this ballistic
Neutron to take now I actually got this
wrong I guess I wasn't paying so much
attention the answer is that the neutron
will continue to travel in a straight
line it's not going to be slowed down by
drag because drag depends on friction
with like the air you're moving through
and it depends on surface area so the
surface area of a single neutron is so
small it's going to be nimble in this
case and it's definitely not going to be
pulled down by gravity either because on
the scale gravity is going to be way too
small as well so we can ignore those
factors and know that if you fire a
single neutron it should just continue
to travel in a straight line provided
nothing else happens to it so here we're
introducing a first complication we are
firing our single neutron and we've
arranged two magnets of opposite
polarity that means one is like a North
Pole and one is a South Pole to create a
magnetic field perpendicular to the path
of the neutron so it's going to travel
through the magnetic field given our
understanding of classical physics how
might we expect our neutron to be
affected by the magnetic field if we
treat it as an uncharged mass so the
answer here is that we would still
expect the neutron to travel in a
straight line even through this magnetic
field because we're treating the neutron
as we understand it as having no charge
and something would only be affected or
deflected in a magnetic field if it had
a charge so yeah we'd expect the neutron
to behave like any other uncharged mass
in a magnetic field and be unperturbed
however this isn't what we observe our
neutrons path is deflected much like we
would expect from a charged particle
like an electron or a proton but it is
to a much smaller degree it's deflection
because this neutron is I guess
unexpectedly
deflected in the magnetic field it means
something else is going on the neutron
is uncharged so this deflection implies
that the neutron has what we call a
magnetic moment essentially that it acts
like a tiny bar magnet this is where the
definition of spin comes in
so uncharged objects sometimes have
magnetic moments if they are spinning so
the experiment is here referred to this
magnetic moment of the neutron as a spin
magnetic moment it has a magnitude and
direction corresponding to the axis of
the spins rotation and it behaves like a
tiny bar magnet in the magnetic field
all right so this tiny bar magnet here
is how we're essentially modeling our
spinning neutron that it's not
necessarily physically spinning it's
just the fact that it's it's deflected
by a magnetic field and this is one way
we might be able to explain that
behavior this page is talking about how
our neutron when going through the
magnetic field the amount of deflection
would depend on I guess how the neutron
is orientated so if it's sort of tilted
upwards or downwards that would change
the direction and which it is deflected
by the magnetic field it's also talking
about how the force that the neutron
will experience that's the force
deflecting it will depend on the angle
that it's spinning a cos theta where
theta is the angle between the magnetic
field and the spin axis of our neutron
okay so different orientations should
result in a different amount of
deflection because you're going to feel
a different force pushing you up or down
the idea here is that if we place a
particle detector after the magnet we
can measure how much the neutrons have
been deflected and then infer which
direction it's spin was directed okay so
that's what this picture here is showing
us all right so we've got another
question we've already fired one Neutron
three
we go to fire a second one what do we
expect to be its deflection the correct
answer was that the deflection should be
random it should be deflected by some
random amount I guess based on its
initial spin axis and how it was
orientated in the magnetic field alright
so now we are generating a constant
stream of neutrons emerging from our
little oven and heading through the
magnetic field and onto the detector so
again a very similar question what would
we expect the distribution of this
constant stream of neutrons to look like
on the detector screen the answer is
that we would expect to see a continuous
distribution centered around zero so
these would all sort of hit randomly
along here based on how they were
orientated okay so here's where the kind
of strange thing comes in whilst that is
what we would have expected our
classical expectations for how the
neutrons would be deflected Neutron spin
does not behave like a classical
property and we get something that's a
bit of a surprise so instead of seeing
this continuous spread of neutrons we
get two distinct bands one at the top of
the detector and one at the bottom so
according to our analyzer neutrons are
only found in two possible States out of
the infinite number of random
orientations which they could have had
spin must be a quantum property because
it is quantized that means it comes I
guess in discrete packets it's only
allowed to have certain values please
leave your classical expectations at the
door so this is really an introduction
into why aspects of quantum physics
become really surprising all right we're
heading over into the next section we
were in classical expectations now we're
off to quantum surprises before we go
any further here I'm going to recap the
stern-gerlach analyzer which is actually
just what we've been talking about but
let's just recap some of the notation
that's going to be used so this is the
analyzer it just consists
neutron coming in that magnetic field
that we saw and this analyzer is able to
distinguish the output into two possible
things spin up or spin down so those are
essentially those two bands we were
seeing on our detector screen the
brackets around our spin up and spin
down errors are called kits and they're
a way of referring to the state of the
particles in each Channel so either the
up channel or the down channel similar
brackets are around our and put here
which is around our wavefunction just
saying that that is I guess our mystery
state before we figure out whether it's
spin up or in the spin down state this
question here is saying oK you've been
running the experiment for a while
you've got your stern-gerlach analyzer
you've got your two output channels what
how do you expect the neutron States to
be distributed between the spin up and
the spin down state and the correct
answer is that you would expect a
roughly even 50-50 distribution half of
them are up half of them are down then
brilliantly websites also talk about how
this probabilistic behavior is at the
heart of quantum mechanics who touch
more on that later but essentially
they're using now as a chance to talk
about how you know we've got these 50/50
distributions with seemingly no way to
figure out whether a certain particle
will go spin up or spin down but you
know averaging over all the time you get
a 50/50 probability it seems a very
random process okay so we're going to
extend the experiment a bit here and the
first part of it is just our ordinary
experiment and we've been talking about
we're going to add a second
stern-gerlach analyzer such that the
output which is in the spin up state
will become the input and to our second
analyzer and then again it will split it
into being either spin up or spin down
we're asked what we expect the
distribution to look like as it emerges
from these
to output states here okay and the
correct answer is that all the neutrons
emerging from this analyzer will be in
the spin up channel so even though there
are two possible options all of the
neutrons will remain spin up because the
second stern-gerlach analyzer is
essentially repeating the filtering
process that's already gone on and the
first one
everything that emerged from here was
spin up so everything passing into here
should be measured spin up again like
you if you measure it twice in a row you
will expect to get the same thing this
result doesn't just hold for two
analyzers in a row you would expect to
see that if you place an infinite number
of these analyzers one after each other
such that you're always you know using
this spin up result as the input for the
next analyzer at the very end of this
infinite chain you will still be
measuring all of the neutrons to be
spanned up just to check how things were
working when they did these original
experiments they thought okay well what
if we flip the second analyzer upside
down that means that the magnet would be
essentially flipped the north and pole
north and south poles of the magnet
would be on opposite sides and then we
you know used these spin up as the input
state for the second analyzer which has
flipped what would you expect the result
from that to be the correct answer is
that the all the all the neutrons would
emerge this time from the spin down
channel so they'd be measured down here
it does kind of make sense because
literally you have just turned this
analyzer upside down so even though
you're measuring them now as spin down
you're really still doing what you're
doing before you're measuring they're
measuring them as spin up you've just
flipped which way the up and down
channels are appearing to you all right
let's move on to the next chapter which
is observables this chapter is starting
off by talking about a spinning top so
this is just a classical spinning top
like a toy and they're saying that we
could observe the x y&z
components of its spin axis so that's
just what angle that's on I guess in
three-dimensional space to find its spin
victor you could also have angular
velocity and kinetic energy as physical
observables associated with this spin
these are things we could figure out
about the classical spinning top toy the
easiest way to measure the direction of
the spin vector would be to rotate your
perspective you could take a photo from
you know the top the side and the front
and get these different images and you'd
be able to figure out everything you
needed to know about this spinning top
this part down the bottom says that
we've had some success understanding
neutrons as microscopic spinning tops
even though the spin vector can only
point up or down and that's a little bit
odd let's see if we can measure the
other Neutron spin components with an SG
analyzer by rotating our perspective
that means finding out more information
than just on the one axis we've been
looking at so yeah this is how we've
currently been looking at the experiment
this is the Z direction that's straight
up and down that's the way our magnet
has been aligned and that's the only
axis on which we have any information so
to gain more information about the spin
vector of these neutrons we could rotate
our analyzer by 90 degrees so now the
magnet is flipped so that it's aligned
on the x axis so from left to right and
this should help us to gain actually
some more information so from our
understanding what would we expect to
observe from the second stern-gerlach
analyzer when it's aligned along the x
axis and we're feeding in you know our
experiment we've already done where
we're feeding in the spin up and put
into it the answer of what you would
expect to see is that the neutrons are
not deflected at all the reason why I
picked this answer
it's expressed down here as well as that
the Z and the X axes are orthogonal to
each other so at 90 degrees and any
vector that had been aligned along one
of the axes has no component along the
other orthogonal axes that's a feature
of linear algebra and a feature of two
things that are at 90 degrees to each
other there is no overlap so we know
that the filtered Zed spin directions so
that's essentially our input here
they've already been filtered to be
completely spin up they should not have
any component in the X direction so we'd
expect them to not be deflected at all
in an excellent analyzer all right
that's what we expect classically to
happen however this is another surprise
this is not what we observe we again see
a binary result so half of the neutrons
are deflected as though their spin were
aligned along the positive x axis and
half as though they were aligned along
the negative x axis so we still have
half the neutrons coming out of each of
these two channels this is really
strange because what it says is that a
particle that had seemed to be aligned
along the z-axis now seems to also be
aligned along the x axis and a normal
vector cannot be aligned along two axes
that are at 90 degrees to each other at
the same time so this is really quite
strange you could repeat this
measurement with other rotations of the
analyzer and you continue to always see
this binary result the way that we
explain this is that you know spin is a
quantum property it can only be observed
in a given set of quantized values in
this case zero is not one of those
values even though that would be the
classically expected solution but it
does say here that there's a glimmer of
classical physics remaining if you
repeat this experiment many times you
find that the number of neutrons which
had initially
to be spin up and I now mission to be
either spin left or spin right well
they're measured an equal number to be
spin left and spin right so the average
deflection through that second analyzer
is zero you know if you take the average
of all of these spin left and spin right
you end up with being in the middle even
though no neutrons actually got to the
middle that's still where the averages
and that matches with the classical
expectation so here's a really important
idea and it's in a box here at the limit
of many quantum measurements the average
will always approach the classical
result even if individual experiments
appear to violate the classical law this
is called the classical limit alright so
this is quite important and and goes on
to explain how we get the classical
world around us that makes sense from
quantum physics which appears to defy
what we know you can see this in another
example here which is a little bit more
tricky but still makes sense so if you
were to rotate the second analyzer by
some arbitrary amount of theta which
isn't 90 degrees so he has just been
rotated a bit classically you would
expect the amount of deflection of the
neutrons to depend on that angle it
would be cos theta and in the quantum
experiment even though we still get this
binary there either all the way at the
top of the detector all the way at the
bottom the amount by which they go to
the top or the bottom
means that if you take the average of
all these positions here you would still
end up with this line of neutrons here
at cos theta you would still end up with
the average even though all you got was
this binary distribution where nothing
seemed to be in the right place they
actually average out to be what you
would classically see I guess this
explains why a large part of quantum
behavior seems so counterintuitive
macroscopic objects so something like a
baseball consists of a very large number
of microscopic quantum particles
and we only observe their averages we
only observe the average behavior of the
quantum particles unless we are doing
these kinds of experiments and looking
very closely actually at the quantum
behavior itself all right so let's keep
going it was a bit weird that our
neutrons were aligned along two
different axes that were orthogonal but
let's add in a third analyzer to the
experiment aligned just like the first
one in the Z direction based on our
results so far
what channel would you expect the
neutrons to emerge from in the third
analyzer okay so the answer I chose is
what I would classically expect that all
neutrons would emerge from the spin-up
channel the reason that I chose this
answer was because you know when you
didn't have this sideways whine and you
would have just put this one after this
one
if you've measured it spin up in the
first place you should always measure
its spin up again afterwards that's what
I was it answer I was very confident on
I was happy that it told me that I was
correct so this kind of blew my mind
actually but when you go to the next
page you find out that this is not what
we observe the neutrons leaving the
third analyzer are again split with a
50/50 probability in the spin-up and
spin-down States even though we diverted
all the original spin down neutrons away
from the experiment and the first
analyzer so you know that really sort of
surprised me to actually have my
classical expectations proved wrong in
this experiment right here so let's stay
with it and try to understand why this
happens essentially how can we explain
this contradictory result the answer was
that measuring spin along the x axis
which is what we did in the middle
destroyed all previous knowledge of the
neutron spin state what this result
demonstrates is another key feature of
quantum behavior again in another
important box and that's that quantum
measurements are not as gentle as
classical measurements sometimes
measuring a quantum state
can change the state for all future
measurements so essentially our unknown
state which emerged from our oven was
never really aligned along the positive
or negative seed axes but by trying to
measure the Z component of the spin we
changed the state to being one of the
two possibilities spin up or spin down
measuring another component caused the
same result the X analyzer reset our
prepared spin up state tuned to being
one of two completely different
possibilities spin left and spin right
you might ask can we be more clever in
designing the experiment such that we
don't disturb the system but know there
is a fundamental incompatibility and
trying to measure the spin component of
a quantum object along two different
directions so we say that the x and z
spin components are incompatible
observables we can never know them both
simultaneously so revisiting our
classical model of that spinning top toy
we see that not being able to measure
both the spin Z and spin x components is
completely different from the classical
case where we could measure all the
components of the spin vector easily at
the same time we could just take these
three different pictures from three
different angles we need to determine
all three of these components to
determine which direction the spin
vector is pointing and four quantum
objects the different spin components
are incompatible we can never know which
way the neutrons are pointing when we
say the spin is up we really mean only
that the spin component along one axis
is up this property isn't permanent
since measuring the spin along any other
axes will essentially reset the spin
okay let's move on to the last section
of this part here which is measurement
and memory so what we encountered in
that last section was the measurement
problem in quantum mechanics and
we could not devise an experiment
capable of measuring the neutron spend
components without destroying previously
collected information along the way it
appears that the experimental apparatus
we were using must disturb the Neutron
spins while observing them making it
impossible to precisely determine the
direction of the spin vector this
interesting consequence of quantum
mechanics is not limited to spin as
we'll see in later chapters well spoiler
this is what I've sort of been talking
about recently on my channel to do with
the double slit experiment and how and
that experiment we were using a detector
to whitter measure where a particle went
so it's passed through two slits and how
that act of observing collapsed the
wavefunction so this does relate to the
measurement problem as well but I'm not
talking about finding the path of a
particle here and said we're talking
about trying to measure its spin how
this also seems to affect fundamentally
what's going on in the experiment the
act of measuring I will say as a further
disclaimer which I did say in a previous
video of mine there is no reason to
think that a conscious observer is
needed as part of this process but
rather that information about the
particle becomes available to an
external environment you don't need a
human eye to be watching that data come
in it's just the the fact that that data
exists does impact the experiment so
let's examine this idea a little bit
further if we can by nice pin lift and
spin right beams of neutrons which
emerge from our second analyzer the way
that we combine these beams shouldn't be
important we're using magnets the
footing the beams back into alignment
and we have to assume that these magnets
here are not affecting the spin of the
particles in any way so we're regather
in both our sets of neutrons back here
putting them through another zid
analyzer and what would we expect to get
out the end here when I answered this
question I said I would expect based on
what I know here that the neutrons would
be split evenly between both channels
the reason I answered this was because
you know when we weren't recombining the
data that's what we were seeing we were
seeing that this information of the
initial measurement was lost a new
measurement is made which essentially
reset the data and then this was reset
to being you know 50/50 up and down that
was the correct solution I'm brilliant
for what you would expect but what
really got me was that actually not what
we observe so the result that we
actually observe is kind of absurd and
contradicts our expectations but all of
the neutrons emerging from the third
analyzer here are in the spin up
position and this really blew my mind I
was like what I thought I was
understanding this but let's just have a
little bit of more of a look here to
understand so what it what has happened
is that the X component was never
actually observed so the state wasn't
reset that means here when we put in
this X analyzer because the data was
arranged or set up such that it could
not be observed was region balled back
into the third analyzer the effect of
resetting the quantum state did not
happen so let's see what they say in
their words although the neutrons have
gone through an X component analyzer
which we've noted completely destroys
information about the Z component of the
spin the X component of the neutron
channels was never actually observed
recombining the deflected beams so
measurement could not tell them apart
seems to behave as though the
measurement never occurred
the neutrons still remember that they
were measured to have spin up along the
z-axis so they go back to behaving as if
this middle analyzer wasn't there at all
and it was what we saw before if you
input this spin up Neutron into another
analyzer that's measuring whether it's
spin up or down it will always at an
infinity of analyzers continue to be
missions then up it was only when we
started to measure different axes that
we were resetting these spin values but
if we attempt to reset them and don't
actually have the data in such a way
that it's measurable this resetting
process does not occur I'm sorry if you
can hear me I'm in the audio my
neighbor's cat is at the door trying to
get me to feed it which I'll probably do
after I finish recording this so what
brilliance is here is that the
measurement problem is essentially more
sinister than disturbance caused by our
magnetic fields so what we might have
thought was a shortcoming of the
experimental setup turns out to be a
reflection of something much deeper it's
the act of measurement itself that is
changing the state of our neutrons from
the point of view of the neutrons they
were never observed and no incompatible
measurements have been performed that
would reset their States the role of
observers and quantum mechanics is
completely unique and has no classical
equivalent this fundamental quantum
mechanical property is the most
important we've learned so far so here's
our third important idea in a box I'll
read it out observers can change the
state of quantum objects quantum states
are reset by observation itself though
the point in the experiment when this
occurs is still the subject effective
debate I'm not quite sure what that last
point means about the debate over which
point in the experiment this occurs
maybe they'll get more in depth into
that but I can't say for sure I
understand what exactly the debate is
there if we try to understand what's
going on here by analyzing
yes I guess the path of a neutron
between two analyzers an X and Z aligned
one we can note the probability of the
neutron emerging from each state so this
is using classical probability the way
we would normally do things like with a
probability tree so if we had a 50%
chance of coming out of the span left
state and then a 50/50 chance here so
this is actually a 25% chance of the
original neutron ending up here 25%
chance of ending up here 25 25 so you've
got our four different options and a 25%
chance of ending up in each of these
places but when we put each of these two
results up here together what we end up
with is a big contradiction we end up
with two paths that were 25% each up
here adding essentially to 100 because
this is where we see all of our neutrons
ending up and same here we get 25% plus
25% equals zero because none of our
final neutrons ended up in this state so
we have classical probabilities not
adding up to give us what we actually
saw in this experiment what can we
conclude from these results the answer
is that quantum measurements can't be
treated as independent events so the way
this would work in classical probability
is that you know this 50-50 chance here
is completely independent of anything
else on the tree on this 50-50 chance
here and and of things that have
happened previous to it in classical
probability every time you branch out
this is I guess an independent event but
our quantum measurements can't be
treated like that
I hope the way that I've described this
idea here makes sense because I didn't
use a lot of math that I really wanted
to give a good primer to some of the
quantum ideas that are going to be
involved because in the next video I
want to jump back into the mathematical
foundations
use the math actually that we developed
in the previous two videos to the Sun so
that's this stuff you know the linear
algebra and direct notation to actually
describe this experiment very
mathematically and understand the
approach and and it's well it's called
the Fineman path integral formulation or
summing over all histories so there's a
lot more cool stuff we can do and I hope
that the next video I make is going to
bring together all the videos so far so
all this knowledge if you've been
following along with me bringing it all
together to have quite a good way of
mathematically describing and
interpreting these experiments and I
kind of look forward to doing that and I
hope to see you again in the next video
if you don't want to wait for me to make
that next video I encourage you to jump
on brilliant dot all yourself and work
through at your own pace you can try
some of those questions that pop up on
the side and there's a lot more material
on this website then I could ever cover
so if you want to learn more I think you
should go on to brilliant yourself and
have a look really an hour supporter of
my channel so you can go to brilliant
org slash Tibby's and sign up for free
and the first 200 people that follow
that link can get 20% off an annual
premium subscription so thank you to
brilliant for helping me to continue
make videos I'll see you guys in the
next episode and in the meantime I'll be
reading your comments and hoping that
you guys have learnt some stuff along
this journey as well and it'd be
interesting to see what further
questions you have and what you'd like
to learn about more see you then